a lot of people act different when
they're still the same person without
really doing internal work to become
better
always
okay I'll give you an example so
when I was in college I used to drink
like
um I mean I don't know I don't know how
colleges are here but in the US like
it's very much like you play flip cup
beer pong yeah you know and after
college I was like you know what I'm
gonna stop drinking I just I just like
stopped right and except my thought was
I'm young now it'll probably be easier
to quit now I don't want this to become
a problem I'll just stop there's always
gonna be a part of me that wants to
drink that still is part of who I am and
once you do something like like I feel
like you're that part of your brain it's
always there
and you can choose not to do it but
there's always like a higher risk you're
going to do it again it's the same thing
with like girls being hoes they can stop
doing it but there's always a part of
them that's going to be ho